das ist wirklich ein kurioses
stellenangebot das deutsche zentrum für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr sucht
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer die
insgesamt 60 tage einfach nur herum
liegen müssen in dieser bettruhe studie
werden die auswirkungen der
schwerelosigkeit auf den menschlichen
körper untersucht hier passiert wirklich
alles im liegen das waschen essen und
selbst der toilettengang dafür gibt es
dann rund 16.000 euro und man ist
wichtiger teil der weltraumforschung
tricks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen das ganze
experiment dass das deutsche zentrum für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr im auftrag der
nasa und esa aus für dauert 89 tage
ganze 60 tage davon werden die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer liegend
verbringen ohne kopfkissen und die beine
leicht erhöht auch der kopf muss runter
die einstellung des bettes sorgt für
eine liegeposition in einer sechs grad
kopf schieflage
das alles hat natürlich auch einen grund
schließlich sollen die bedingungen des
weltalls simuliert werden und vor allem
der abbau der muskeln gefördert werden
denn genau das passiert bei einer reise
in den weltraum die schwerelosigkeit
führt zu einer sinkenden knochendichte
und dem abbau von muskeln aber es gibt
weitere physiologische veränderungen zum
beispiel verschieben sich die
körperflüssigkeiten in richtung kopf was
folgen für das herz kreislauf system mit
sich bringt hohlräume im gehirn fühlen
sich mit flüssigkeit und die augen
werden schlechter wir hatten ja darüber
berichtet mit hilfe der studie sollen
gegenmaßnahmen entwickelt werden die
diese negativen effekte der
schwerelosigkeit für männer und frauen
im all mindern so werden die insgesamt
24 freiwilligen in zwei gruppen
eingeteilt nach einer 15 tägigen
eingewöhnungsphase werden die einen 60
tage lang einfach nur durchgängig in
ihren betten liegen die anderen werden
in regelmäßigen abständen in eine
spezielle zentrifuge die sogenannte kurz
am human zentrifuge gebracht in
liegender position natürlich solch eine
zentrifuge könnte nämlich bei ausflügen
ins weltall künstliche schwerkraft
erzeugen und sich so positiv auf den
menschlichen körper auswirken
letztendlich soll die studie in köln
zeigen ob solche kurzen momente der
gravitation einen gesundheitlichen
vorteil mit sich bringen nach den 60
tagen im bett ist dann eine zweiwöchige
reha also
rehabilitation mit physiotherapie
vorgesehen sie ähnelt dem prozess den
astronauten astronauten nach ihren
missionen durchlaufen um wieder zu kraft
zukommt und muskeln aufzubauen alle
phasen und experimente werden natürlich
medizinisch überwacht doch auch wenn das
ganze erst einmal nach einem äusserst
schwierigen job angebot klingt ist das
experiment doch nicht ohne die zwölf
teilnehmerinnen und zwölf teilnehmer
müssen zum einen test zu gleichgewicht
muskelkraft und regelmäßigen
blutabnahmen teilnehmen zudem ist die 60
tägige bettruhe sicherlich nur am anfang
entspannen denn schließlich ist es keine
option auch nur kurz aufzustehen alles
passiert ihm liege neben duschen essen
die freizeitgestaltung und auch der
toilettengang hier wünscht man sich nach
einiger zeit bestimmt dass endlich der
wecker klingelt und man aus dem bett
aufstehen darf der einzige luxus sowohl
rücken lager auch bauch und seitenlage
sind erlaubt in seinem einzelzimmer wird
man mit einer kamera überwacht um auch
wirklich eine korrekte körperhaltung zu
gewährleisten
das kann bestimmt schnell langweilig
werden wenn auch besuch ist in diesen
zwei monaten nicht erlaubt und so rät
das dlr dazu sich in dieser zeit einer
bestimmten aktivität zu widmen wie etwa
dem lernen einer neuen sprache als
aufwandsentschädigung für die
vollständige teilnahme die auch noch
vier vorsorge und vier nach untersuchung
beinhaltet gibt es dann 16.500 euro
sogar 500 euro mehr
bewerben können sich gesunde frauen und
männer zwischen 24 und 25 jahre die
deutsch sprechen und nicht rauchen cool
es ist ja wirklich dass man als
freiwilliger wirklich wesentlich zur
raumfahrt forschung bei trägt nicht
umsonst werden die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer von den forschungsteams des
dr
auch als terrestrische astronauten
bezeichnet wer das übersteht hat
vielleicht das zeug zum astronauten oder
zu astronauten in diesem video ihr
erfahrt ihr direkt von alexander gerst
persönlich was ein echter astronaut an
kräften aushalten muss im astronauten
trainingszentrum und abonnieren würde
ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran